PROFESSOR: We've mentioned
the P equals NP question
a number of times now as
the most important question
in theoretical computer
science, and we've
said that one way to
formulate it is exactly
to ask whether there's
an efficient that
is polynomial-time procedure
to test whether or not
a formula in propositional
logic is satisfiable.
Now, why is that such
an important problem?
We're not just logicians and
we want to know whether or not
some formula is satisfiable.
How did it take on this
enormous importance
and apply to so many fields?
And illustrating how you could
use a satisfiability tester
to factor efficiently
is a good hint
about why it is that all
sorts of things reduce to SAT
and why it, in fact, is such
a centrally important problem.
So let's suppose that we
have a satisfiability tester
and use it to find how
to factor a number n.
Now, the observation
begins with how
you use a SAT solver
is that you can begin
by writing or observing
that it's easy enough
to design a digital
circuit that multiplies,
that does arithmetic
multiplications.
In other words,
it's got some number
of bits reserved for
an input x, a k bits,
and another k bits
for an input y,
and it's got 2k output
lines that produce
the digits of x times y.
You might need one extra
digit, but never mind that.
So this is a multiplier circuit
takes an x, a k bit x in
and a k bit y in and it
spits out the product, which
is another 2k bit
number, and this is not
a terribly big circuit.
The naive way to design it
would use a number of gates
and a number of wires that was
about quadratic in the number
k.
It's easy enough to
design one of these things
where the size is literally
bounded by 5 times k squared,
maybe plus a constant.
And so this definitely
a small polynomial.
Given the number of bits
that I'm working with,
it's easy enough to build
this multiplier circuit.
Now, suppose that I have a
way to test satisfiability
of circuits.
How am I going use this
multiplier circuit to factor?
Well, the first
thing I'm going to do
is let's suppose the number
that I'm factoring is n
and is the product of
two primes, p and q.
Those are the kinds of n's
that we've been using in RSA,
and let me also observe that
it's very easy to design
an n tester-- that is, a
little digital circuit that
has 2k input lines and
produces on its one output line
precisely when the input is
the binary representation of n.
So let's attach this equality
tester that does nothing
but ask whether it's being
fed the digits of n as input
and it produces an
output, 1 for n and 0
if the input pattern is and
the digital representation,
the binary representation
of anything other than n.
That's another trivial
circuit to build.
So we put those two together,
and now watch what happens.
I'm going to take the circuit
and set the first of the input
bits to 0, and then I'm
going to ask the SAT
solver the following
question-- is there
a way to set the remaining
input bits other than 0?
So I've set the first one to 0.
What about these other bits?
The SAT solver can
tell me whether or not
it's possible to get a
1 out of this circuit
with the 0 there fixed.
So let's ask the SAT
solver what happens,
and the SAT solver
says, hey, yes, there
is a way to fill in
the remaining digits
and get an output 1.
Well, what does that tell me?
Well, it tells me that there
is a factor that starts with 0,
so let's fix the 0 based on the
fact that it's possible for me
to fill in the remaining digits
with the bits of factors x
and y that equal n.
Let's try to set the
second input bit to 0
and see what happens.
Well, we'll ask the SAT
tester, is it possible
now to fill in the
remaining digits
to get the two numbers x and
y that multiply and produce
n and therefore output 1?
And the SAT tester
says, no, this
is an unsatisfiable circuit.
You can't get a 1
out of it any more.
That tells me that I have to
set the second bit to 1 in order
to have a factor of n where the
x and y will multiply together
to be n.
All right, fine.
Go to the third bit, ask
whether or not 0 works.
The SAT tester says,
let's say, yes.
So then I could fix 0.
I now know the first
all three bits of x.
And of course, I go on
and in 2k SAT tests,
I know exactly what p and q
are, and I have, in fact, found
the factors p and q.
So that wraps that one up.
That's how you use a SAT tester.
You just do the
SAT test 2k times
and you factored
this 2k bit number.
And of course, if the SAT
test is polynomial in k,
then doing it 2k times just
is also polynomial in k
with one degree higher.
Now, the satisfiability
problem, as we formulated,
was a problem about formulas
that as you wrote out
a propositional formula
and asked whether or not
it was satisfiable,
and I'm instead
asking about satisfiability
of binary circuits.
But in fact, as we did
in some early exercises,
you can describe
a binary circuit
by assigning a fresh variable
to every wire in the circuit
and then writing a little
formula around each gate which
explains how the input
wires to that gate
are related to the
output wire of that gate.
And that little formula explains
that wiring of that gate,
and you take the "and"
of all those formulas
and you have a formula
that is describing
the structure of the circuitry,
and in fact the formula
is satisfiable if and
only if the circuit
can produce an output 1.
So we really have
by assuming that I
could test satisfiability
of formulas,
I can therefore test
satisfiability of circuits,
and therefore I can factor.
So that's the simple trick to
find a propositional formula
that's equisatisfiable
to the circuit--
if the circuit
produces output 1 if
and only if this formula
of about the same size
as the circuit is satisfiable.
And that's the last piece
that I needed in order
to completely
reduce the factoring
to the satisfiability
problem, and you
could see that this is
actually a general method that
will enable you to reduce most
any kind of one-way function
to a few SAT tests.